une course solidaire pour soutenir les
ânes à la jeune fille de 11 ans est
atteinte du syndrome cardio faciaux
cutanée une maladie génétique principe
de l'événement chacun réalise sa
performance de son côté une course qui
s'est déroulée en famille pour les ânes
à damas et des sensations qu'elle aime
vraiment courir comme ça dans la joie
let avait toujours très heureuse avant
fin d'été souriante elle avait des cris
de joie c'est pour faire avancer
l'association c'est sûr c'est bien comme
ça en plus son plein de monde le fait il
ya une ambiance qui règne on est
ensemble on s'entraide et puis on avance
ensemble
l'inscription se déroule sur le site pro
timing jusqu'au 6 février
pour participer à la course plusieurs
possibilités il ya 6 formats course
marche marche nordique et et course à
pied en 5 ou en 10 km c'est un euro du
kilomètre ils le font voile à chacun de
leur côté ça permet de pouvoir le faire
ou qu'on soit en france ou sur sur le
monde et une fois qu'on a fini l'autre
course en fait on renseigne directement
sa performance sur sur le site
léana à participer à la course en
joëlette la famille à travailler en
équipe et c'est relayé pour courir à lée
10 km une course réalisée en 1h10
sachant qu'on a marché on a fait des
échanges pour la joélette donc on est
content de temps ont changé il y avait
un pompier qui était venue pour un petit
peu gédé et on avait pris un vélo pour
tourner au chichi on est un petit peu et
puis y'a des moments
objectif de cette course virtuelle
récolter des fonds pour l'association au
fil de les anars un budget pour financer
des équipements pour enfants porteurs de
handicap et acquérir un vélo cargo pour
les annales pour qu'on puisse partir en
vtt avec ses frères et c'est un vélo
dans lequel en fait on peut la soir et
un soir également son chien avec elle et
ça nous permet d'être autonome et de
pouvoir partir dans les champs en
famille pour l'heure près de 400
personnes se sont déjà inscrites à
l'événement